the vulnerability of democracy which has
been a remarkable remarkable system and
i don't have to extol the benefits of it
but the vulnerability of it
has always been
the um internal conflict that produces
itself as anarchy um in world war ii
uh four democracies
chose to be autocracies
um because there was internal disorder
and there was this
the belief will somebody bring about
order and get control of the situation
you know that was in um germany italy uh
japan and spain
they were parliamentary dictat
systems that turned themselves over to
that so both systems
have
vulnerabilities um i think the main
thing that we need to think about
is those vulnerabilities democracy is an
amazing system because it
the the adherence to the rules and the
system and the checks and balances is
quite amazing and it gives it a
flexibility to change without civil wars
but there has to be the respect of the
rules and when you see something like
that they will not
accept
elections
or they will not accept rules
and history is shown when the causes
that people are behind are more
important to them than the system the
system is in jeopardy so we have a
situation that's very much like that
in terms of let's say the 2024 elections
i
believe that there's a very high chance
that neither side will accept losing
for example and so we um
we have that kind of a situation so one
would hope that one could rise above the
disagreements
and rely on the system uh for resolving
disagreements because if if that doesn't
happen then we have our own uh chaos
so the kind of the trend that started in
2020 this or i mean i mean i suppose
it's been there
it's been growing
a rep one representation of this
internal disorder has been the growing
trend of being skeptical about the
results of the election
well it started before that
there was the emergence of populism
where before
president
trump was elected
he was basically elected
as a populist because there was a large
percentage of the population
that felt that the system didn't work
for them and he tapped into that and he
was largely elected as a populist leader
first populist leader in a developed
country
um and so populism began that then
and that was a battle of one group
against the other group and so since
then it's been like that and it
continued to grow
you